this video is brought to you by
expressvpn
you guys might very well love me or hate
me after watching this video so what are
we going to talk about well quite a lot
actually like I said last week the rated
on akashima as well as the subsequent
battle that takes place is longer on its
own than many arcs in this series and
longer than most manga in publication
ever get the chance to be needless to
say wano is an absolute Beast a unit of
an arc has more fights than any other
section of the story I've covered and
comes packaged with choices both
visually and narratively that have
fractured a fan base as loyal and die
hard as they come that's where I come in
here she comes to wreck the day join me
friends as we finally conclude wild this
week and attempt to analyze and break
down exactly what injected so much
basically I want to try and figure out
what made this act such a divisive one
at least from my perspective was it a
great Arc was it as bad as many touted
to be only one way to find out I'm toy
not Mark and these are my first
impressions of thoughts on and review
for the conclusion to the longest Arc
and battle in one piece history let's do
it let's finish onogoshima
[ __ ] it down
okay so I spent a large portion of last
week's script sharing what I loved about
the beginning of that raid and I gotta
say it's true to my experience I did
like the vast majority of it safe for
one or two key aspects I had issues with
which I did share last week also but
this week we're diving into material I
am far more mixed on so let's try and
Tackle this with an open mind and let's
try to do it in some sort of cohesive
order Luffy ends up losing to kaido in
his first Tango with the great monster
himself falling from the roof and
ultimately the now floating island of
onigashima all seems lost leaving Yamato
then being tasked with holding back his
own father this is a very cool moment in
the series and while the story does pick
up again this marks the beginning of a
midpoint crawl for me waiting for Luffy
first off let's clear something up I am
not saying nothing good comes from this
choice to bench Luffy for a while I love
that the fact the cruise resolve isn't
affected by this sudden shocking
negative news that they keep fighting
because they know what Luffy is made of
but at the same time in a similar way to
how I felt during death note's second
half where there was a compelling story
to be told between mirror and light but
there's all this extra stuff in between
to distract us from that until later
near come together at the end to deliver
the final finale which is awesome but
that midpoint in that series is rough
that's sort of how I feel about wano at
least in this particular section and
while this battle needs to have a bunch
of different things happening all at
once when there's no movement on the
main event and we're stuck in this
obvious waiting period I almost entirely
lost interest until Luffy resurfaced
there are plenty of interesting moments
with plenty of potential like Momo's
addressing to those in battle in Sanji
carrying around wounded Zorro is always
hilarious but again it all feels like
padding to me now this isn't to say that
when Luffy isn't on screen I'm bored far
from it I love Luffy as a character but
it's important for other characters to
do their thing for many chapters without
his story interrupting them so that's
not necessarily my issue my issue is
that the fight itself isn't even
progressing in the background we know as
an audience that the main battle this
Arc is about is now on pause we know
they aren't suddenly going to affect any
other battles they aren't going to crash
through a wall out of nowhere we know
that we are very much in a waiting phase
for an indeterminate amount of time
waiting for Luffy to get back up find
his way to the roof and then resume and
pick things up where we left off and if
the action was something spectacular
something I was going to lose my mind
over and get completely captured by
emotionally or whatever then fine but it
wasn't cluttered pages and lack of
clarity for the purposes of this
critique let me say that I'm aware I
might be a unique case but there's also
a good chance that I'm not I've touched
on this countless times throughout my
review series and it's only gotten worse
and worse the series has soldiered on
unfortunately at times while I was
reading this simply turning a page to be
greeted by a wall of text and dozens of
panels crowding and cluttering the
layout it made me completely lose
interest in Reading any further and it's
not because I'm not interested in
Reading or because I don't find oda's
Art interesting far from it I love
reading books and oda's artwork is
eccentric and fun but both of these two
things don't come together very well and
made for some really tough reading
sessions for me with this approach I
think fundamentally stripping one piece
of the gravitas it could otherwise have
had if it was laid out clearly and I
mean this in the most sincere and
Earnest of ways so allow me to explain
what I'm trying to say in filmmaking
animation and even comic layouts
presentation is a monumentally important
aspect in the creation process to
consider whether you're writing a book
or a script for a film the key visual
elements need to be clear for the
readers or viewers take Ian any gift
scene meaning every scene needs context
to some extent we need to know where
characters are specifically where they
are in relation to one another and in
particularly within a battle we need to
know and understand the consequences of
being in a specific location shows and
stories are made and broken by this
fundamental principle many Thrive and
many Fall From Grace potentially as a
result Game of Thrones has some terrific
examples of both great and terribly
conveyed battles this big brain time
[Music]
season 5 episode 8 of Game of Thrones
plays host of one of my favorite battles
in this series entitled hardhome this
battle or Massacre while frantic and
chaotic never loses itself in the chaos
and always keeps a clear track of the
scene and the locations of Any Given
characters within it the set pieces are
simple and clear to understand with the
gold clearing the minds of the
characters and by association the
viewers watching at home the same can be
said for season 6 episode 9's Battle of
the bastards in Game of Thrones with
that very conflict playing host to one
of the scrappiest most chaotic battles
in the series itself and it's one of my
favorites starting out as a
psychological battle with one life in
the balance quickly becomes a Savage
swarm of people struggling to make sense
of the craziness they've been swept away
in it indulges in this craziness just
long enough to capture the essence of
the fight itself but never for so long
that we lose track of what's going on or
taking place and largely this is true of
one piece's onigushima towards the
beginning but one piece keeps the
craziness going for a very long time and
eventually I got a little
season 8 episode 3 entitled the long
night is one of a few episodes from Game
of thrones's final season that became
married as time soldiered on outside of
some insane narrative choices one of the
main issues I have with this battle is
how difficult it is to see and how damn
boring it was as a result a battle built
up for eight seasons literally since
episode 1 season 1 concluded in one dark
hard to see episode thankfully however
one piece doesn't have the same
narrative problems far from it but when
it came to conveyance I genuinely had no
idea where different characters were and
in many instances totally lost interest
in the villains they were fighting the
tobiropos are a group of enemies Our
Heroes need to defeat in order to win
the day alongside Luffy and I honestly
couldn't tell you a single thing about
most of them I know one of them by name
and despite Oda going out of his way to
give them all unique personalities I
just didn't feel like I spent nearly
enough time to get to know them to
justify how long they took to dispose of
but that's some negative stuff I think
it's time to move on to some positive
stuff foreign
Switching gears for a moment to
something I enjoyed let's talk about
Yamato's involvement with the story
despite only playing into this Arc
towards the back end Yamato has received
more characterization flashbacks in
connection to the greater one piece
world than most of the characters
introduced during wano and maybe even
most of the story Yamato knows he can be
his father but in the name of Odin
Yamoto will hold off kaido this is
pretty much the only fight during the
middle section I had any interest in
despite it at times feeling quite
stretched out one moment issuing the
challenge to kaido then disappearing for
chapters and chapters only to resurface
for the end of a chapter Stinger as a
Zone fruit user again it looks cool but
even with this battle a battle that I do
very much like it still feels like it's
trying to stretch content for the sake
of other less interesting fights to take
place or at least less interesting to me
once it does however show up and spend
time exploring the character of Yamato
it becomes more engaging and interesting
burying witness to Yamato's fabled
meaning with Ace was a wonderful way to
introduce the character to the story
while also tying him to key aspects of
the greater world right off the bat from
this point immediately I was inclined to
lean in and listen to this character's
scenes because of the connection and due
to that I became much more attached to
them quicker furthermore while spread
out the battle Yamato takes part in
against kaido is once again filled with
flashback sequences offering up another
Peak into their past together detailing
the torture and Punishment kaida would
lay before Yamato forcing starvation
upon him for long extended periods of
time which makes it all the sweeter when
the battle Works in his favor
it's a nice idea to help change the tide
of battle utilizing tama's Powers but
perhaps the best part of this downtime
for me was the promise of something more
foundational to the story being revealed
not at all to do with Thomas scene
unfortunately but during jimbay's battle
with who's who we learned something
feverishly interesting a former member
of cp9 he was imprisoned for failing to
guard a certain fruit that fell into the
hands of Shanks and ultimately our
little stretchy boy Luffy immediately
this woke me up from the disinterest I
had typically been feeling during this
section and sprinkled across a number of
chapters is this Illuminating
conversation between these two
concerning the origin of Luffy's gumgum
fruit and of course tell us of the sun
god naturally all of these components
are connected which I'll get into later
but for now they were the only thing
that kept me engaged when reading and is
honestly very fascinating stuff I love
it when Oda does this stuff broadly
speaking I think this Tama Nami and usop
storyline stuff is hindered more than
any other part of this manga there's
plenty to enjoy with Zoo tsunami staying
true to her convictions not running away
but there's so much dialogue in the
layouts for this section particularly in
chapter 1018 are just awful for me to
read there's just so many panels so many
reactions so much flavor text that I
would normally greatly enjoy but found
at this point particularly with my
interest waning that it directly
affected my enjoyment
Robin's fight on the other hand was a
nice bit of respite once again the
narrative significance of Sanji asking
for Robin's help and the small exchange
she shares with Brooke before whipping
out some awesome moves on one of the
Toby rapos was great to see as many of
you know I'm a big fan of Robin's more
understated personality and seeing that
contrasted starkly against her newly
revealed demonic form makes this contest
my favorite amongst the Toby Robo
battles but enough of that [ __ ] time
for Luffy's return
foreign
there's nothing more annoying than
paying money for a subscription only to
find out you're missing out on so much
content just because of where you live I
just found out Crunchyroll has the
entirety of Dragon Ball and Dragon Ball
Z up for streaming but it's blocked in
my country there are so many shows that
have met this fate but thankfully I can
now access content from around the world
thanks to expressvpn what's great is
that expressvpn lets you control where
sites think you're located and they've
got almost a hundred different countries
for you to choose from that means no
matter where you are you'll have access
to content from all around the world
it's so easy to use too you just open up
the expressvpn app on your computer or
even your TV you pick a location hit
connect and boom content for everyone
it's super fast and definitely quelled
my fears about VPN slowing down my
connection it works for Netflix Amazon
Prime Disney plus and tons of other
streaming services it's really a
no-brainer so if this all sounds good
head to expressvpn.com forward slash not
Mark to find out how you can get three
months off expressvp and for free that's
expressvpn.com forward slash nutmarc
link is in the description
[Music]
I've touched on this countless times
since Punk Hazard but Momo's Journey
throughout this story has been nothing
short of incredible and now that Luffy
is back on the scene pushing towards the
finale this is where the tale starts to
pick up steam once again thankfully and
as I was reading this for the first time
when Luffy asked moment to turn into a
dragon and lift him up to the roof of
onigushima I couldn't ask for a more
perfect full circle moment for these two
characters and the relationship to have
having come out of a pit and punk Hazard
having pushed him to become a man now
Momo finds himself assuming more
responsibility than anyone his age
should ever have to shoulder begging to
use the ripe ripe fruit to turn him into
a fully grown man appropriate I think
for this story and his whole characters
are seeing as they've both been about
needing to grow up too soon in a violent
and harsh world and the action is also
so perfectly laced with so much of this
wonderful characterization this series
is famous for Luffy coaches the
increasingly confident but still timid
Momo into battle with kaido eventually
coaxing the now full-grown man in Dragon
form to bite his back with Luffy
exclaiming that's an emperor of the sea
you just took a bite out of is there a
single thing left in this world for you
to be scared of that's just a
wonderfully simple yet insightful Luffy
line of dialogue only Oda could write
with him going on to Proclaim don't
worry about kaido I guarantee I'll win
as long as I'm alive I'll have infinite
chances this sort of character writing
is exactly the type of inspirational and
uplifting stuff I read this series for
Luffy's boundless confidence and
conviction in his own abilities
translate so powerfully in these moments
and Oda does a wonderful job of
communicating that very aspect
Zoro and Sanji take on King and Queen
sanjin zoro's dance with king and queen
was honestly a lot more engaging than I
otherwise thought it would be I suppose
with the past 20 or so chapters not
delivering enough to capture my
attention it's to be expected that's
what reminders at however a great story
can win me over any time and including
core character moments for the likes of
these two strong components of the straw
hat Pirates was just what the doctor
ordered sanji's conflicting thoughts
surrounding his usefulness to his
captain and his body's full capabilities
compromising his moral code was an
interesting one to tackle for sure part
of the reason I never anticipated I
would enjoy this fight as much as I did
was due to the fact that while Queen and
maybe King were two of the more
well-known underlings of kaido I still
didn't really feel any meaningful
emotional connection to them Queen was
probably the one I had the biggest
emotional response to due to his actions
in udon but outside of that I felt it
was lacking however Oda manages to
circumvent this very issue by creating a
living manifestation in Queen of
everything Sanji rejected from his
family utilizing all the gear his
relatives made famous in this story that
was honestly a brilliant idea and while
I do have issues because this page makes
itself known on the pages of physical
manga I think online it makes for not
only a tremendous finish but a fantastic
final panel in this compelling fight of
the chapters concerning these two
however I believe I found Zoros oddly
enough to be the most compelling
particularly in chapter 1033 unlike many
other Straw Hat Pirates Zoro has
remained more of an enigma than pretty
much any of them a man of few words that
allows his actions to speak for
themselves getting the chance to peek
behind that man of a few words and allow
the picture to do all the Talking was
interesting to say the least learning
the history of his blades and part of
his origin to boot with of course his
battle with King revealing the
henchman's true appearance culminating
in similar fashion to that of sanji's
bout a superbly large and spectacularly
composed spread and I swear okay this
will be the last time I'll mention the
page layouts but I think this one griper
has is kind of interesting I understand
that more and more manga isn't read
physically and that's to be expected
it's expensive and takes up space so
while I anticipate manga to go the same
way as records could set tapes and CDs I
personally love collecting physical
copies of manga and it's my preferred
means of consuming them personally which
brings me to my gripe this right here is
one of oda's favorite page style layouts
for big spreads it takes up roughly
two-thirds of a page while also allowing
room for other panels around it and it
looks kind of nice it's cool to see some
large panels every now and again and
given that Oda will very very seldomly
use an entire page for a single panel
let alone two pages for a single panel
like other mangas do this is the closest
we get to consistent large panels within
one piece this would be fine if not for
one small issue I've grown to nitpick
and then hate as I've read this story
when reading it in physical manga it
destroys the image as it's not taking
into account the creases in between the
two pages of the manga okay rant over
time to talk about more cool stuff law
and kid take down big mom generally
speaking I think from the king and queen
fight onwards the action really started
to hit its stride for me while I
appreciate the dedication in giving
killer and Hawkins their time to shine I
didn't really feel much in the way of
entertainment from that section I know
for a fact there are those out there
that love that material and for that
reason I'm glad that it's there it's
just not for me the fight with big mom
on the other hand had a tremendous
amount at stake and interestingly had no
straw hats involved giving credibility
to the idea that they needed an alliance
with these guys in order to defeat these
monsters together and the fight was
actually kinda dope too big mom looks
terrifying in this exchange standing
atop Armenians growing in size taking
things to The Other Extreme as she finds
two formidable foes standing before her
kid gets downed and then she redirects
her attention when suddenly she gets
stabbed
I've never seen that in one piece I
don't think it totally took me by
surprise and as the fight presses itself
onward that's right it keeps going after
she gets stabbed in the face I can feel
Oda taking his foot off the break and
placing it firmly on the accelerator as
this fight goes from strength to
strength painting Big Mama's more
monstrous as the pages and chapters tick
on by the scale of the battle elevates
to absurdity as law punctures her body
with his blade and finally kid Blaster
the Kingdom Come With His Giant Cannon
all of that sounded really
moving on and just when I thought that
was the ending it keeps on going if
nothing else I think this fight
emphatically achieves this mission in
painting big bomb as an unrelenting
force of nature the likes of which could
only be taken out with what looks like a
nuclear explosion on this page spread
then and only then could Kaiden law be
declared the winners
now
as many of you know this is where the
big elephant zunesha comes in and one of
the most okay yeah that's appropriate
there that's when one of the more
divisive aspects of the arc becomes
apparent as we return to kaido and
Luffy's fight news reaches kaido and by
proximity Luffy that Lin Lin has been
defeated which means the fate of the
battle lies squarely on the outcome of
this one bout this is an awesome setup
but knowing where this is going what
makes it even more effective is the time
limit and tension that spawns from that
very limit being imposed Luffy declares
that he is going to go all out not hold
anything back assume gear 4 and keep
punching until he is absolutely nothing
left either kaido gives out or Luffy
gives out and we're hoping it's the
former and as time ticks on by will he
gets some good licks in kaido doesn't
even seem to be taking this nearly as
seriously as Luffy is still arguing with
him managing to on the Fly learning his
most advanced movements and if that
wasn't bad enough the tide seemed to be
turning and Luffy is running out of
juice def defiant as always he gathers
his strength for one last fantastic
attack and
Luffy loses
the winner is kaido this moment takes us
from the highest of highs we were flying
to perhaps one of the lowest moments in
this series Luffy is declared dead and
the looks on the faces of those he
trusted befriended and traveled with are
nothing short of heartbreaking nami's
face in particular strikes a chord with
me here the first person who ever really
understood her and had the power to
change her life for the better she's
told that he's died and Oda captures
that feeling beautifully in this tragic
reaction panel offers torture chaos and
horror Reigns from the heavens as kaido
does what he does best and then
for the first time in 800 years
Joy boy returns
gear five Luffy's gear 5 was a form that
gave me pause for a second one that
caused me to reflect upon the entire
series
in a new light now communicating my
complicated feelings surrounding this is
going to be difficult without examples
and so I want to start this dissection
of the form off by addressing what made
one of my old favorites the classic
Super Saiyan form and transformation
from 1991 so popular and interesting to
Millions around the world even to this
day I think part of the reason Super
Saiyan as a concept and form is so
special resides largely in the contrast
it creates between its raw strength and
the sadness of its initial execution so
what do I mean by that well in the very
instant Goku achieves this form he
becomes in effect the personification of
pain loss and retribution in the series
echoing the themes of the Ark and indeed
the broader story as it stood then
achieving a massive emotional and
cultural effect around the world this is
all of course to say that while enjoying
the surface level goodness that scene
brandishes is okay I think it's
additionally important to consider the
impact or thematic relevance this
transformation or Transformations like
this offers the greater story a given
character is under going naturally it
must look the part in order for it to be
an effective marketing tool however if
we decide to look past the gimmick and
the capitalistic intent behind the
design narratively there's a lot for us
to either subconsciously or consciously
latch onto here super saiyan as a form
comes from an individual reaching their
Breaking Point snapping mentally letting
oneself fall into an abyss of anger far
beyond any rational thought it's born of
frustration and rage lashing out
uncontrollably like trying to harness
the power of the sun if only for a
moment visually it was striking in its
Simplicity but thematically it was a
rebirth amid immense trauma an instant
change that allowed the user to walk a
dangerously fine line and wield a
necessary strength to Vanquish a
formidable evil in the case of Goku that
evil was Frieza and there's something
unbelievably cathartic about that
following the success of that watershed
moment from Manga and Anime history like
any other Trope that becomes popular
hundreds and hundreds of other news
stories sprouted from that newly fertile
soil trying their best to in good faith
emulate or straight up copy the concept
in the hopes of finding comparable
massive successes some innovated on the
idea and found tremendous success While
others didn't however now over 30 years
later it's easy to get lost in cliche
expectations of what a transformation
ought to be now while Akira Toriyama
tapped into a specific type of
transformation through anger the
mechanism by which one transforms
narratively is far less important than
the narrative connection or story that
it represents within the character
itself this is again all to say that one
doesn't need to channel anger to
Faithfully apply this narrative
technique in fact you could in theory do
the exact opposite and see a similarly
effective narrative result which brings
me to Monkey D Luffy's now somewhat
okay I swear that's the last time is now
somewhat controversial gear 5
transformation
discussing aspect aspect of character as
old and as well worn as Luffy is an
intimidating task at least for me I've
grown up with the likes of Goku and
enjoy analyzing him for that very reason
despite my thoughts on certain aspects
of the series and indeed the character
not gelling with certain people or
populations online I at the very least
know what their arguments are which
allows me to at least feel like I did my
due diligence before I release a given
video with Luffy I don't have that same
security and so for the purposes of this
section I chatted with two lifelong
friends of the series to get a better
idea of what they thought and so the
following are my fully synthesized
thoughts on the topic of Luffy's gear 5
transformation despite anger being a
powerful albeit somewhat now socially
safe Catalyst for modern Shonen authors
to grant their protagonists any
transformation Luffy's undergone through
gears has never and I mean never been
about anger each deer of course is
wildly different and instantly memorable
in their own ways but ultimately the
Common Thread isn't anger resentment
hatred or any other comparably powerful
negative emotion in instead it's quite
simply his imagination for the purposes
of this argument let's take a walk back
through memory lane to what stands out
to me as being significant with his
development concerning the gear system
let's start with gear two the very
moment Luffy learned there was a trick
to cp9 soru or shave he used his own
imagination to craft a method of
equating their speed it might have been
demonstrated and unveiled to US during a
moment of 10 significance similar to
other more traditional shonins including
Dragon Ball however the impetus for the
Gear 2 technique being developed came
from Luffy's ability to see what was
possible and where he needed to be to
match the competition and every
subsequent addition to his gear system
followed suit using his imagination to
manifest his own destiny he wanted to
punch Haider and therefore created beer
3 upon learning haki from Raleigh during
the time skip Luffy Incorporated it into
his fighting style and created a new
gear 4 capable of taming the Beast he
was training against combating cracker
he utilized his own size to generate
more defensive power Allah man against
katakuri he needed to go faster and did
so by way of snake man every single time
Luffy's development eventually produces
something new they have always come from
his own ability to see what he needs and
using his imagination cobbles together
some solution from what he has available
to him and I think that's what's
important here it's not necessarily what
he's responding to but the fashion with
which he responds to that thing this is
all again to say that Luffy's gears at
least as far as I can see it aren't
simply a power up for the sake of making
him stronger they're a full-on example
of his Ingenuity to create and shape his
body to fit the scenario and find a way
to win and in these instances the limit
was always his imagination the more he
learned the broader his perspective grew
and ultimately the more Fantastical his
Transformations became to me that's what
gear 5 is it's a fantastic and
Fantastical culmination of everything
Luffy is and always has represented in
the story
Freedom echoing precisely what he told
Raleigh and shaki on sabaudi way way
back that he wants to live Freer than
anyone else furthermore it's brilliant
and somewhat appropriate in my mind at
least that there's a population of
people online that refers to gear 5 as
quote Tune Force and I say appropriate
because it's evocative of exactly the
attorney
s and explore art so effective I mean
what else broadens the scope of
imagination more than cartoons in Dragon
Ball Goku's sudden and abrupt
transformation into the Legendary Super
Saiyan saw a once happy-go-lucky young
man focused on light-heartedly improving
himself through martial arts shift
violently into a monstrous and
terrifying force of nature one that
would aggressively bark at his own son
to leave and one that would strike fear
into the most terrifying entity the
universe itself had ever seen Goku and
Luffy have been compared quite
frequently and are similar in many
important ways however one of their many
foundational differences comes in how
their stories have their personalities
interact with the world where Goku's
story details his journey to surpass his
personal limitations imposed by his own
physical body time and again Luffy
specifically focuses on his ability to
overcome limitations placed onto him by
external forces to Brave the harsh and
dangerous oceans that he himself can
drown in to broaden his Horizons far
beyond what modern man have ever seen
and to achieve true Freedom no matter
how dangerous it can be and so in the
same way Super Saiyan represents Goku
shattering his own previous physical
limitations this bombastic and
Fantastical gear 5 form represents Luffy
taking the freedom that he seeks for
himself animation and Comics after all
have always pushed the boundaries of
what is considered possible and paying
homage to that childlike wonder and joy
is not only I think a brilliant move by
Oda but one that Roots the story once
again in the type of character writing
I've praised throughout this
ever-growing series of reviews
encapsulating everything someone named
Joy boy should represent in the hearts
and minds of society not only in the
world of one piece but perhaps ours too
with it in addition to that heightening
the Thematic counterbalance between
Luffy and kaido to boot I mean to see
this you need look no further than this
speech by kaido himself he says
abilities alone cannot conquer the world
because only hockey can transcend all
kaido himself has internalized hockey as
the be-all and doll as long as the
battle was a 1v1 foundationally built
around the strength of One's Own
willpower kaido was going to be the
winner he was the strongest 1v1 as he
was touted as being one should always
bet on him he conquers all however as
Luffy has said many times in the past he
has never been nor has he any intention
of becoming a conqueror he was never
about that quote I'm not going to
conquer anything the one who is the most
free is the pirate king the moment Luffy
becomes the freest is when haha you
don't think I noticed but I noticed you
sneaky bastards the moment Luffy becomes
the freest is when his willpower is
truly capable of matching kaido's and
what does he say when he beats him what
does he say to defeat the mindset of the
strongest in all the world who believes
equality is based around physical
strength well Luffy wants to create
quote a world where his friends can eat
as much food as they want in a battle of
wills on top of the world itself Luffy
is the personification of boundless
freedom and compassion imagining a world
that isn't just limited by his own
enjoyment but those of his friends of
course kaido was always going to win a
1v1 brawl but the whole point of this
battle from the very beginning was that
it wasn't simply a 1v1 contest a battle
of Brawn Luffy had always been supported
and buoyed by the people around him he
gained strength from them and there's no
greater example of that being the case
than this moment right here if Luffy had
done what so many other Shonen
protagonists had done and lashed out in
a fit of traumatic rage against kaido
surpassing his physical limits once
again in order to overcome this
monstrous individual it would have in my
view not only being massively bereft of
any creativity or originality but would
have also been far less emotionally and
narratively resonant with the rest of
the story that has been told up until
now in the same way Game of Thrones as
Ramsay Bolton was quoted by saying if
you think
echoing the realistic and tragic themes
of its story so too does Luffy Echo the
themes of his in his battle with kaido
through the very transformation mechanic
popularized by Dragon Ball over 30 years
ago in response to the need he has to
create a world for his friends to have
enough food to eat he imagines and
manifests his own unique solution to
that problem and in the process of
writing this Oda himself managed to
manifest a worthy modern interpretation
of the classic Shonen transformation
popularized all those years ago in my
honest opinion I think this
transformation fits one piece better
than perhaps any other and so in effect
one could say that this transformation
gear 5 could be the most thematically
resonant transformation The One Piece
Series has ever seen but that's just my
take
victory
Luffy's ultimate defeat of kaido is a
simple yet brilliant one because of his
Reliance on the straw hat pirates with
their unwavering belief and support in
their Captain he was able to with the
resistance save wano and make good on
his promise whereas on the other hand
kaido's ranks are full of dissension and
betrayal through the likes of his
so-called alliances all in all I am very
happy with the conclusion to this one
with the final speech the people of the
flower Capital coming from the young at
heart kozuki mominosuke echoing his
father's beliefs the words his people
needed to hear and giving me shivers in
the process it was a spectacular speech
and furthermore a terrific reveal of
what he in fact looks like I've
speculated for quite a bit during my now
very long series of reviews concerning
this very Arc itself that once the dust
does settle on wano and the day is one
the world outside would be very very
different and I think it's really cool
to see that they're making use of that
device in the story with new bounties
being announced the world government
scrambling people trying to attack one
or know that kaido is gone it all paints
a picture of a much more aware and wild
world ready for Luffy and his crew to
arrive particularly now seeing as he's
one of the four Emperors of the sea
hearing about the pluton was kind of
cool too like seriously I don't think I
would have guessed that about one or
hundreds of years ago even if I had a
hundred years to think about it but it
being underwater in this weird Bowl
shape that's such a
it's a really fun visual but now that
we're moving into what could only be
described as the end game of one piece
with Shanks making his move for the
grand treasure itself and Luffy setting
sail with Yamato and toe as his new
crewmate
I don't think I could have asked for a
better ending to this overall Arc and I
think my experience with wano has been
brilliant overall despite the midpoint
of the raid itself being extremely slow
and dry in my opinion with paneling that
Nico Robin would have trouble
deciphering okay and maybe maybe that
was a bit too was not too far maybe it
was too far I genuinely had a very good
time reading this Arc over the last
couple of years I can now safely say
that I've been a fan of this series for
years how crazy is that and I can't wait
to see how this one ends but until then
I've been toying up Mark I'll see you
all next time and thank you all so much
for watching
[Applause]
[Music]
they didn't exchange